welcome back everyone i did the updated
version for probably the final trailer
for doctor strange and multiverse of
madness uh this i don't know if it
warrants but this may be a spoiler
warning uh even though technically it's
kind of all out there i just organized
every scene in the trailers to put them
in what is essentially a sequential
order that i've seen from plant leaks
and whatnot
so enjoy again possible spoiler warning
and please subscribe
thanks
[Music]
the nightmare begins
[Music]
prove it
wonder
i knew someone later you'd show up
i made mistakes
and people were hurt i'm not here to
talk about westview
then what are you here for
i need your help
guess what
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories our other avengers
we'll get you back in the lunchbox
i do it i become the enemy
it doesn't seem fair
[Music]
[Music]
night where
[Music]
sorry steven
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
things just got out of there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you